[Music]
ryan we got some surprise questions we
should answer today all right about
tina's question alabama i have an
expansive collection that i've outgrown
and no longer enjoy is it worth trying
to sell it even if i don't think anyone
else would want it
so we were dealing with danny's
bobblehead earlier on this private
episode here this is really where i'm
gonna appreciate the live callers
because we can ask for more information
yeah yeah what is it a collection of is
it a collection of bobble heads right is
it a collection of bottle caps right
like i want to understand your
collection i want to understand the
motivations behind that collection
i also want to understand is it clutter
now what is clutter clutter means
something is getting in the way right so
something that is clutter for ryan might
not be clutter for me right but if he
owned all of my underwear which are size
medium they'd be clutter for him because
they would just be really snug that's
right super snug yeah and so what i
realized is like yes if i just handed
him all of my underwear it would totally
be clutter but for me i have the
appropriate amount of underwear for my
life and so i want you to understand
your collection you say it's an
expansive collection if you're asking
the question one of two things is
happening either it's bothering you
enough to ask the question which is more
likely than not or two
other people are bothering you and
telling you you shouldn't have a
collection like that and it's making you
think that you shouldn't well there are
no shoulds and so hold on to the
collection if you want if you feel like
it's adding value to your life if you're
doing it intentionally
wonderful
why would you get rid of something that
is adding value to your life right but
if it has become clutter it may have not
been cluttered a year ago two years ago
10 years ago but if it is cluttered
today that is a sign
to start to let go i don't mean let go
of the whole thing trash the whole thing
although that's one way you can handle
it
but maybe
simply
calling
the
collection having a funeral for the
things that are no longer serving you
might actually enable you to enjoy
pieces of that collection much much more
yeah absolutely i just want to give
props to tina for like
just recognizing and admitting i mean
she's like i have an expansive
collection that i've outgrown
and no longer enjoy so like just being
able to
see that with your collection that you
obviously have put time and effort into
yeah like that's a pretty big step so it
sounds like she's asking like how to let
go of this and
what i'll say is whatever collection it
is there's probably someone out there
who will at least take it off your hands
for free yes and i'm willing to there's
probably someone who would pay a little
bit of money for it so
um
you may not think that there's someone
out there but i guarantee you there's
someone i mean
on craigslist we had like i you know we
moved uh in montana we had some boxes
from uh usedcardboardboxes.com
we were done with them i'm like i'm not
gonna hoard these boxes so then i was
like put them on craigslist like anybody
need carver boxes they were gone in like
an hour immediately yeah immediately
yeah and i was like in my mind i'm like
man i don't know who's gonna just take a
bunch of cardboard boxes but it's like
someone else who wants to move or in
tina's case someone else who is
interested in the same thing she used to
be interested in
yeah
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free